[Music]
in our morning rounds October is Breast
Cancer Awareness Month and this morning
we're focusing on male breast cancer the
disease in men accounts for about 1% of
all breast cancer cases this year it's
estimated close to 2,700 men in the US
will be diagnosed with breast cancer our
doctor Tara and Narula is here Tara how
much of this problem how much of a
problem is this well Anthony
statistically speaking it's not that
common about 500 men will die this year
from breast cancer compared to more than
41,000 women but the mortality rate in
men is higher and in the case of Tammy
Porter she says the lack of awareness
around the disease caused a delay in her
late husband's diagnosis it never even
occurred to me that he would any type of
cancer certainly not breast cancer four
years ago Tammy Porter's husband Mike
first started noticing symptoms of
breast cancer he literally had a pea
sized lump under his areola and his left
side and he pointed it out to me one day
just kind of matter-of-factly and I said
oh that's interesting and you know there
was no discussion of it ever at all
until probably three to four months
later and he said I think this is
getting bigger and at that time it was
much closer to a dime-sized and his
nipple was inverting and I could tell
that there was some growth there after a
visit to their physician Mike was
quickly scheduled for a mammogram what
did Mike think about the mammogram
discussion he I think he was embarrassed
a little it was really hard for him to
mention the words breast cancer he would
say I have cancer but it was hard for
him to actually discuss the breast
cancer part you know it was very
ostracizing walking into a clinic that's
full of pink and you know the mammogram
room that literally says women only he
underwent a radical mastectomy and
radiation but the cancer metastasized to
his lungs spine and brain two and a half
years after diagnosis Mike passed away
if we had known three or four months
prior you know it may have been a stage
one diagnosis it was an aggressive
cancer and so it might have been very
different have we known si
you think if this had been on either of
your radar screens then when he first
felt that lump for sure you potentially
could have gotten treated earlier and of
course would have been different
absolutely I can only imagine that you
know being having that earlier
intervention would have definitely
changed the course for him particularly
in men that early detection is critical
in general men have lower survival rates
than women do after they get diagnosed
with breast cancer
one third of dr. Sherin Giordano's
patients are men and she says men often
get diagnosed with more advanced breast
cancer in part because of lack of
education some of the risk factors have
been include genetic factors such as
Braca mutations exposure to radiation
therapy in the past a family history of
breast cancer so if there the
first-degree relatives had breast cancer
they have more than double the risk of
having breast cancer themselves it was
knowing his family history that helped
former NFL player Paul Dombrowski my mom
was a breast cancer survivor for about
25 years so as soon as I felt the lump
I just knew right away that it was
breast cancer in 2013 he was diagnosed
with breast cancer I immediately thought
how do I battle this what's the next
step it's almost like a football player
where you're injured how do I get back
on the football field Dombrowski is now
in remission and his mission is to raise
awareness a lot of guys I played with
they say I didn't know men could get
breast cancer I said bro you got breasts
you know call them what you want me to
compex your chest it's Anatomy and the
rarity thing I think we should kind of
drop that term because it's again it's
not rare to that man and that man's
family as for Tami she hopes sharing her
loss will help save lives
he vocalized the number of times that he
hoped that his life wasn't in vain and
that
that it would mean something and that we
would be able to change someone else's
life by telling her story the FDA
recently put out guidance recommending
men be included in breast cancer
clinical trials it's typically only
women participating in these trials and
for men the symptoms are usually a lump
behind the nipple or some bleeding wow
it's so interesting that early detection
in in men is especially critical yes
because most men pick it up at a later
stage and at that point it's
metastasized and the survival rate is
much lower it's picked up early the
survival rates equivalent to that of
women I love Dombrowski's basically
infomercial for this it's like bro you
got breast it can happen to you too
exactly I'm struck by how giving she was
to share the story though because it
will certainly help people who are
watching today who never thought about
it men will now look at it very
differently I think that's important
because bro
yeah she's got breasts you both do King
to human resources thank you very much